le recours au télétravail sera rendue
obligatoire je dis bien obligatoire une
obligation de trois jours par semaine et
pour une durée de trois semaines minimum
depuis les annonces du premier ministre
les entreprises n'ont eu que quelques
jours pour s'organiser face au
renforcement du télétravail ce lundi 3
janvier peu de bureaux occupés dans ce
cabinet d'experts comptables installé à
voisins le bretonneux la pme était
fermée entre noël et le jour de l'an en
cette matinée de rentrée il fallait donc
établir les nouveaux plannings là on
vient de diffuser un mail général à tous
en dit en rappelant les règles et en
disant qu'on allait mettre en place les
trois jours de télétravail obligatoire
demandé par le gouvernement l'idée c'est
ça c'est de pouvoir organiser une espèce
de permanence au bureau sans que tout le
monde soit là en même temps et en ce que
tout le monde puisse venir un peu au
bureau à des moments où tout le monde
peut se retrouver aussi au moins entre
on travaille en binôme donc lisez c'est
que les binômes puissent continuer à
travailler ensemble sur le site de saint
quentin en yvelines l'entreprise compte
25 salariés
la généralisation du télétravail n'y ait
pas problématique avec un système
informatique et digital qui rend l'accès
à distance possible l'expérience des
précédents confinement a permis de se
roder en la matière on avait déjà fallu
télétravail à 100% lors du premier
confinement donc pour nous ce n'est
qu'une
une remise en place du télétravail
on avait gardé une journée par semaine
pour tous les collaborateurs et en est
qu'on est un cabinet à ses tournées le
digital ça ne pose pas de problème ce
que tous les collaborateurs ont accès à
distance et ont accès aussi bien aux
logiciels qu'aux pièces comptables pour
encadrer l'obligation les contrôles
seront multipliées selon le gouvernement
chaque société contrevenants s'exposent
à 1000 euros damende par salarié